Good evening, everyone.
Welcome to the MIT Museum.
My name is Brindha Muniappan.
I'm the Director of
Programs here at the museum.
And I'd like to welcome
you to tonight's event,
a discussion about the art
and science of solar lights.
We're thrilled to be able to
offer this program this evening
in collaboration
with Arts at MIT.
We're going to have a series
of paired discussions.
Tonight, you'll get to hear from
artists, designers, architects,
technologists, engineers.
It's a pretty fantastic
program that we
have for you this evening.
I hope you'll enjoy it.
And without further
ado, I'm going
to allow Leila
Kinney, head of Arts
at MIT to introduce the program.
So am I on this or this?
I'm on this.
Great.
So thank you all for coming.
And I wanted to say a few
words about the first section
of this.
This is a format that
we're using tonight
that I think the MIT
Museum has specialized in.
Those of you who have come to
the Cambridge Science Festival
know about this, Big
ideas for Busy People.
So forgive are flying through
many interesting issues,
but I think it's
an interesting way
to make some of the research
and technology and innovation
here at MIT sort of
accessible in a general
and fairly efficient way.
So as Brindha mentioned,
I'm the Head of Arts at MIT.
And you may or may not know that
we actually have a major arts
award here, the Eugene
McDermott Award in the Arts
at MIT, which was created by
Margaret McDermott in honor
of her husband Eugene who
was the founder of Texas
Instruments.
And they've been long time
benefactors and supporters
of MIT.
It really reflects her
vision and the vision
of the 13th President at
MIT, that it's very important
to integrate the arts into an
institution primarily known
for science and engineering.
And perhaps one of the
reasons that many of you
are here this evening.
Can I just get a sense?
Has anybody heard of the
McDermott Award before?
Great.
Good.
Thank you.
And I think our 2014 recipient,
Olafur Eliasson, who was here,
has recently become
familiar with it.
A very important-- a very
important part of the award
is the residency,
because we want
an artist to sort of engage
with the MIT community
in a way that is,
we hope, mutually
enlightening and beneficial.
So Olafur's practice-- and
may I ask another question?
How many of you were able
to attend the public lecture
last night in 10250?
Oh good.
Excellent.
Well, for those of
you who weren't there,
I'll just say a few
words about his work,
not to take too long
on the introductions.
Olafur's practice is
very wide ranging.
And we could have
focused the residency
on any number of things.
He's well known for his
large scale installations,
for temporary
pavilion's, architecture,
experiments with sensory
perceptions based light.
I think it's a shame that
artists become known only
for a few works that are
mentioned over and over again.
But it's really, I think,
impossible in his case,
not to mention a couple.
And one is a project from about
a decade ago called The Weather
Project of the Tate Modern.
Have people heard of
that by any chance?
Some people nodding.
Well, the Tate Modern,
as you may know,
is a huge turbine factory
that's been converted
into a contemporary art museum.
And Olafur installed a
project there that, I think,
took everyone and maybe
even him by surprise
because of the intense
public engagement with it.
He created an artificial sun
at the end of this turbine
hall, a mirrored ceiling and
put some fog or mist into it.
And the environment sort of
transformed people's experience
of that space and
of one another.
Over two million people ended
up attending the project.
And it really became
a kind of marker
for a kind of
participatory art that
made one more aware
of one's experience
in a space, which is a really
important aspect of his work.
I think he'll talk a
little bit perhaps tonight
about how we get from big
sun to little sun, which
became the focus of the
residency here at MIT.
You can see in
the window beyond,
if you didn't notice
it when you came in,
this portable solar
powered handheld lamp
called Little Sun that
Olafur calls a work of art
that works in life.
I'll let him explain
more about that.
But we decided to use that as a
means for engaging here with it
the MIT community over the
course of this academic year.
We started off by
having the Little
Sun be a challenge in
a hacking arts event
that occurred in the fall,
which put artists, entrepreneurs
and engineers together.
It was a particular
challenge and one
of the members of his
studio came over--
he's the CEO of Little Sun,
an architect himself came over
to judge that competition
to mentor the students.
Then energy night,
as you may know,
is a big event annually
at the MIT Museum.
It's probably one of the
most well attended events
and certainly the most
populous club for MIT students.
They organize a showcase of
new energy products each fall.
And so in October, we
stalled this exhibition here
and Frederik
Otteson, the engineer
who is the co-founder
with Olafur of Little Sun
came over for that event.
And then this week,
we have sort of
culminated this series of
interactions around Little Sun
with a series of meetings
with people like [INAUDIBLE]..
And this is how we
got Harald engaged
and the J-PAL group
were economists
to evaluate the effectiveness
of various technologies
for emerging economies
through fairly rigorous policy
and technical evaluations and
studies controlled trials.
We've also engaged, of course,
with many other aspects
of the MIT community,
the Civic Media Group.
A group that's exploring open
and participatory documentary
to think about how we
might bring together
users, distributors
and creators,
if you will of Little Sun.
And of course, the programs in
art, culture, and technology
and architecture.
So in a way, this
is a culmination
of that extended period of
an engagement with the MIT
community.
And I'm very grateful to Brindha
and Andrew and their team
for allowing us to sort of
merge this with an opportunity
to showcase some
of the innovation
and new technologies
around solar power
in particular here at MIT.
So a brief couple of words
about Harald and then I'll
hand it over to Harald
and then Olafur.
Harald Quintus-Bosz
was-- well, there's
a very interesting
little story behind this.
When I was running around MIT
trying to sort of describe
this project, the possibilities
for this resonance to people,
I happened to be on the MIT
Museum advisory committee.
So one of the places that
I presented this project
was at the advisory committee.
And Harald's partner and
co-founder of Cooper Perkins--
which is a product
development company based here
in Lexington--
Gerhard said I know exactly
the person you need to talk to.
Harald is not only himself
a graduate of MIT and also
of Stanford-- we got him
first, they got him second--
but had worked with
the D-Lab lab here.
How many of you were familiar
with the D-Lab and its work?
Great.
It's a wonderful program
here at MIT that's--
it's called dialogue,
design and dissemination
for the developing world,
but D-Lab for short.
And it works on creating sort
of effective and appropriate
technologies for primarily-- is
it primarily sub-Saharan Africa
or other countries as well?
Harald will say a little
bit more about that.
They have a wonderful
international design summit
in Africa.
And Harald is just not
only an instructor in D-Lab
and the Chief Technical
Officer of Cooper Perkins,
but has been really active
in that international design
summit.
He also, before
going to MIT and then
to Stanford for his
graduate work, was at IDEO.
So he has, I think, some
very interesting insights
to share with us about
design thinking as a result.
And Cooper Perkins
itself does all kinds
of product development
technologies.
Everything from, I think he
told me chilling technology
for milk in India to increasing
the efficiency of more drilling
equipment.
I'm sure he'll give
you other examples.
So without further
ado, let me introduce
Harald, who will talk about
his solar light project.
And the focus I might
say of this discussion--
this segment is going to
be on design approaches
to design for solar lighting.
And the others will
have different foci.
All right.
Just a quick question.
This the clicker for that?
Oh, no problem.
All right, so thank you, Leila,
for the great introduction.
Said quite a bit.
So, yes.
I'm an instructor
at D-Lab, which
is two floors up from here.
Right up there.
And not so long
ago in 2007, I was
in the fourth floor
building three,
which is that way, meeting
with Amy Smith and Ben Linder
and Patricia and Laura
Stupin and others.
And we are struggling
with the problem
of a teaching tool for IDDS.
And we were thinking of
this particular problem,
which was lighting.
We knew we wanted to target
the developing world.
And we wanted to
think about addressing
this particular problem, which
is lighting in the developing
world.
Which is important, because
people in the developing world
are often lighting
with kerosene.
And not only is it
expensive, but it can also
be toxic to handle
the fumes, et cetera.
So there was a big
opportunity for us
to be able to fuse solar
lighting in a device that
would help us teach
particular skills for IDDS.
And the particular skills
we were looking to teach
were primarily how
to use the lathe.
We wanted we wanted to take
advantage of the lathe.
It's a wonderful
piece of equipment,
it does many operations.
Hinges, all kinds of
things fit together so
beautifully with a lathe.
And it's great to-- it's
a great thing to use.
But before I go
on with the lathe,
let me talk a little
bit about IDDS
because you're
probably wondering
what it might be all about.
So IDDS is a program
focused on teaching design,
creating a network of innovators
in the developing world.
So instead of teaching
students at universities,
we're out there teaching
design to the participants
of the developing world.
And they're from
all over the place.
So the idea is to take
a group like this--
doctors, bike mechanics,
pastors across a broad range
of countries, Pakistan, India,
many countries in Africa,
South America, just everywhere--
and teach these people
how to design and become
innovative to develop
technologies that are
appropriate to them.
And primarily, we do
that with exercises.
In this case, it was
a launch a seed down
the four floors
down in a building
to hit a particular target.
And this was over
in Ghana, Kumasi.
We are also using charcoal.
Amy Smith is particularly
adept at teaching
the methods of making
charcoal, both the creation
of the carbon itself
and then the manufacture
of the briquettes.
So we do that as well.
And we take these people and we
teach them the design process
so they end up being able
to do things like this.
Follow a design
process that looks
familiar to those that
studied engineering
so that they can then develop
products that look like those.
Those are like cassava peelers
and these are treadle pumps.
So that they can design
these technologies
that they need for themselves.
Back to the lathe.
So the lathe comes
in because we wanted
to see if we can mix the lathe
and solar lighting in some way.
So we did the
prerequisite sketches.
Many, many sketches and
thinking bread boards of like,
how might this come together?
What forms might it take?
It all of course had
to work with the lathe.
And we came up with this,
which is right here.
It's a solar light.
And the idea here
was that people could
machine the outside shell.
They could sand the line
on this Plexiglas disk.
So they would draw
a circle, and then
use it use a sander
to sand to the line.
They would use a hacksaw and
a form to bend the handle.
They learned about soldering
both the LEDs and the wires.
Rechargeable batteries,
all of that stuff
was part of this
particular design.
And what ended up
happening was, of course,
that people like Habib--
now he's, I think, in India--
was shown here using the form.
He was making the wire
frame around the form.
There is other
participants that--
I think that's
[INAUDIBLE] on the lathe.
And the drill press over here
to make these holes as well.
So we got everybody involved
in machining as well
as soldering--
learning how to solder,
which was the technology we
wanted to introduce because we
knew that it was important for
people in the developing world
to become aware of soldering
as a method of generating
innovative ideas--
using circuits and electronics.
So then we, of course, used
this tool to teach design.
And then went on to,
in our four-week event,
to present our design challenges
and have the participants use
the skills they
learned in making this
to be able to design,
tackle challenges
with water, energy, sanitation
and many other fields.
So that's what
this light's about.
And just to give
you an idea, when
we got to the participants
on-- this by the way,
happened all in one day.
Because this is just a method
of teaching the participants how
to use particular
tools, it was just
the beginning of the session.
We gave them a bag with a
circuit board, some wires,
LEDs, some plastic plates
and a tube of aluminum.
And I don't have
the handle wire,
but we also gave them that.
And from this, in about
two three-hour sessions--
3 and 1/2 hour sessions,
they made this.
Anyway, that's the solar light.
Thanks for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you.
I started some two years
ago now in collaboration
with an engineer
to think about how
to bring solar energy
into a project which
did several things
besides the main thing
is obviously delivering
light in areas
where there is no
access to energy.
To jump straight into that,
what was very important to us
was the language with which
we could achieve this.
I had worked as an
artist for 20 years.
And the engineer has actually
worked with solar airplanes.
And him and his team was
the first people in '91
to fly across America.
So he knew a lot about--
in a solar airplane-- in the
single-seated solar airplane.
So he knew a lot.
And what we looked at was
that there was already
a number of products or projects
on a sort of out in the world.
Some of which are really
quite amazing projects.
But in general, what
we were interested in
was to tell a
positive story or try
to tell a story that was
not only aimed at the areas
in the world in which one
could not have electricity,
but really a kind of a
global story about sharing
the responsibility about
having access to energy.
So we worked a
lot on the design.
And let me just
briefly show you that.
You have seen it
maybe over here.
This is how it looks.
It has a solar panel,
obviously, on the back.
And it has a LED and
rechargeable batteries
on the inside.
And then it has
this plastic casing.
A UV resistant plastic.
The point here is, we
had a benchmark which
was a production price,
which is about $5.
The production
price had to be low
in order to create something
that would be sellable locally
in areas where
people are normally
spending money for kerosene.
So we were competing with
the oil industry so to speak.
This means $5 is
already quite expensive.
And obviously, we
would very much
like this to be even cheaper.
But with a maximum
of $5, we went
through a whole series of design
processes which led us to this.
Still the ambition was to make
something which is beautiful,
something that feels good,
something that a child who's
our typical user--
a child between 6 and 16 or
a young adult, if you want.
And something that would be
easy to carry around with you.
The sort of beginning
started with,
how does energy actually feels?
And the great
challenge we saw when
talking to people--
in this case,
we would study a little bit
south of [INAUDIBLE] close
to [INAUDIBLE].
We are starting the kind of
abstract of the confidence
how to tell a story.
It turned out it was much
easier to tell the story to be--
it was much easier
if we were emotional
rather than being functional.
So instead of talking
about the practicalities
for four hours of sun and one
evening of light, and so on,
it became clear that
if people liked it,
it was much easier to
convince them to take it.
So this means the
emotional component
was a much stronger
driver than, let's say,
the functional component.
And that inspired the design.
This means that it
had to be something
if it was laying around
and a child saw it,
they would immediately
go and take it.
We got some advice
from some engineers
from different people.
And their advice very
often was robust,
but occasionally misleading.
Such as an advice with saying,
just make sure it works.
Make it high quality,
focus on the functionality
and don't worry
about the design.
This is Africa.
It's much more
important than works.
What do they care about design?
Typical kind of NGO
type of standard.
And obviously, we
very quickly realized
this was not only wrong,
it was also condescending.
And very typical for
the type of language
that is somehow in this area
in which we are working where
a certain part of the
world being resourceful
is addressing a certain other
part of the world which is then
resource weak or resourceless.
And so kind of the idea of
to design, the language,
the campaign, the project very
much also became about building
a language which was
not stigmatizing.
A language which
addressed something
that we shared instead of
polarizing it into what
do we not share.
Say, we have, you don't have.
So we always talk about what
desires do we have in common?
And it's very basic
we want to be happy.
We want to have
something in our lives
that we like or
something we treasure.
We want to care about each
other, and so on and so forth.
And out of that, the
Little Sun project sort of
grew its language.
Should I be flipping
a few images?
Yeah, maybe play the video.
So we have done a number of kind
of campaign related projects.
I'll talk a little bit
about the business model.
But let me just show you one
sort of typical campaign.
See this idea of the
aspiration to be--
how should I say it--
to be positive or to
address something.
Does it play with sound?
Anyway, so this is in
Denmark, the Royal Theater.
I think it's a minute long,
so just have a look at it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So as you can tell,
the idea is to suggest
a degree of interdependence,
shared experience.
This idea of experience
something together,
being a collective.
Experience the feeling that,
I went into this theater
was before a show on a
different or a related matter,
so I went in at the start.
I told everybody,
OK, now like this.
We filmed it.
And then during
the show, we then
edit it quickly together so
that at the end of the show,
I came out again and
showed it to the audience.
And then we sent it
to all of the audience
and asked them to pass it on.
So it became a kind
of an online project.
And the theater was just
to get some sort of stuff
that we could use
in social media.
And this is a little
bit how we try
to work with the
campaigning to address
the idea of having
resources, being resourceful,
doing something together.
Communicating something
which is not necessarily
focusing on the functionality
of it, and so on and so forth.
Having said that, the principle
of this-- as you can see,
you can buy it over here in
the shop-- is that we sell it,
I believe, here it's around--
what is it? $28 or something?
And we are pushing it into
as many shops as we can.
And obviously, this is turning
out to be quite a bit of work.
But we are selling it
here at higher price.
But we are then
delivering it gradually
into sales outlets of various
sorts, private sector, NGO
sector, governmental systems.
And momentarily where we
only work in rural Africa
in eight countries.
So the profit from
selling it here
goes into delivering the
light, but it is also
based on a market
driven model locally.
Meaning that the profit
generated locally then
stays and, hopefully, pays
for ordering a new lamp.
And this, of course, turns
out to be incredibly complex,
but still it's working
relatively well.
Currently we are--
I believe we are
12 people working,
a few in Africa
and a handful of people
doing the office in Berlin.
And it's somehow-- we are sort
of breaking even right now.
So we are quite happy.
We made 250,000 lamps out
of which approximately 200
have been delivered.
One third of those have
been delivered off-grid.
And looking at the
sort of curves,
the off-grid is increasing
a much steeper curve
than the on-grid.
And we only just started
selling them in America online.
And next week, the MoMA store--
of course, the MIT
Museum store comes first,
and then the MoMA store
in New York comes second.
But it's a big deal because then
they send out their catalog.
And it's on the cover and
the back of the MoMA store
catalog-- the Spring Catalog,
I think they call it.
An online and all that.
So slowly, we are
getting it out.
We are just about to also
make a phone chatter which
is going into communication.
We're trying to essentially--
it's just all about money--
getting money.
Sort of collecting money to get
a slightly bigger lamp going--
like a system lamp
going with two
plugs and a lamp and a
ceiling system, and so on.
And this is further
down the line.
So I told you a little bit
about the business model,
about our sort of
campaigning idea.
The idea of awareness, building
and policymaking and addressing
the foot in the door
with solar energy.
And then this role
of the design.
So that was like Little
Sun in a nutshell, I hope.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So now I think we come up here.
These are a little
high, these stools.
I feel like I'm at the
kitchen counter or something.
So I think that one of the
most interesting things
about this pairing
is that you're
both very interested
in empowering people.
But you're coming
at it with very--
from very different directions.
I guess we would call
it the DIY model.
And then this sort
of larger sense.
The significance of
having access to energy,
feeling like you have--
I heard you say a power
station in your hand.
So I'm wondering if we
could expand a little bit
and contrast and
also have you react
to the others model
of approaching
that issue of empowering people.
All right.
Yeah, I would say instead
of maybe DIY, maybe IIY.
OK.
Innovate it yourself.
Because I think what
we're trying to do
is we're trying to make
sure that people receive
a bit of inspiration
and education
in order to be able to
develop technologies
that are appropriate
for their situations.
And that's the way
we approach it.
And we're across many
different fields geographically
and many different
kinds of problems,
as I alluded to before.
So this particular solar,
again, was just a tool for us
to inspire people.
And it worked fabulously well.
We had several
people really wanting
to take off with the light and.
I had to convince
them not to start
focusing on telling that
because it's really expensive.
I said, no, no, no.
Take this inspiration
and rechannel it.
Maybe design your own
light or do something else.
But don't make
copies of this one.
It's a teaching tool.
And do you have actually
information on follow up
or what people did with
their soldering and circuit
making experience thereafter?
So the one individual
that I know
is [INAUDIBLE] He's selling
lights over in Ghana.
And there are other
people that have
done many different things.
Not everybody then follows
through with light making,
because it's not--
the IDDS wasn't
about making lights.
Again, the lights was a tool.
So some people were working
on different technologies
of generating power from water
or other medical challenges.
Trying to solve AIDS
transmission from breast
milk and those kinds of areas.
And yes, some of those
people have continued.
When I was putting the
presentation together,
I was looking at the images
that have taken a long time--
along the way of IDDS.
And I was recognizing
the people.
It's like oh, and they're
doing a water filter.
And they're doing
the birthing kit.
So there's a whole bunch of
innovators out there already.
So it's working.
But I don't have the
numbers in my head
on who has done exactly what.
So Olafur, what do you
think about this idea
of giving people
the tools as opposed
to giving them a sort
of emotional empowerment
and a sense of connectivity, I
think, which is also important?
Yeah, I think the challenge
is to do it in a way
where you don't come across
as the teacher who is giving.
I mean, this of course,
is a little bit complex.
I think what I have learned
from traveling around
in East Africa has been
very much that I'm always
much easier with regards
to being integrated
into a dialogue or working
together on something
when I come to take instead
of when I come to give.
This means if I'm there to
suggest that I know something
they don't and then I
go, so let me teach you,
it's just a little complex.
And obviously, it's--
I mean, coming from a
university like MIT,
MIT is sort of difficult
to go and say that.
So the way we work, we
really go and we base it--
we base the principles
on that we are coming
and we think there is an
opportunity for which we
can learn something,
we can take something.
And we almost--
I wouldn't say we--
it has worked better the
moments where we are--
where we were very clear
to say, we are not here
to teach you anything.
You are great already,
very creative.
We are coming to take.
And this is why we
are asking people
to make their own businesses,
develop their own systems
and so on.
And sometimes, I mean, it's
hard to generalize about it.
But it's also because I work
as a teacher at the [INAUDIBLE]
University and I've been
very interested in the need
to be a little bit sensitive
to the colonizing language
that one, without
even think about,
it brings about into the sort
of teacher-student situations.
And this is where I think the
campaigning of the language
around Little Sun,
we have almost
stopped also when
working in Africa to talk
about off-grid versus on-grid.
Or this idea instead of--
we talk about the right to
power, the right to life.
The right to light, it's
like having a right to life.
And in that sense,
it's something
which is both off and on grid.
I mean, clearly, then
having an education
is different than
having a no education.
Somebody has to teach.
So it's a little more
complex, I can see that.
But I just think--
I think a degree
of sensitivity is
needed when moving into areas
and without being clumsy.
So it strikes me that
one of the huge issues
here is just the
size of this problem.
You often used the
1.6 million people
who don't have access
to electricity.
Creating innovators
one at a time.
It's hard to scale
these things up.
So I'm just wondering
if you could
speak a little bit to that
challenge of scaling up
these solutions.
How does your approach
or D-Lab's approach
deal with that.
Yeah, so that's actually
a very tough challenge
because of the scale.
Also because as we
were talking before,
there isn't a copy and paste
answer to these problems.
So you can't develop a
solution in Guatemala
and expect to run over
to sub-Saharan Africa
and have it take off.
You need to be quite
knowledgeable about the space
where you're going into.
So, yeah, at D-Lab,
we're particularly
focused-- one of the
classes I'm teaching
is design for scale,
which is an effort
to continue that educational
process for the students at MIT
on how to design their
technologies for higher volume
manufacturers so they
can be impactful.
We also broaden in the
students the point of view
what impact is so then it's
not head counting or dollar
counting.
But it can be broader
in terms of who benefits
and how they benefit.
So you can think about
scaling in different ways.
So yes, it is a challenge.
And we spend time instructing
students on how to do it.
In the developing
world, it's different
because the resources and the
education, everything else
is slightly different.
So there's more of an
organic growth model
happening in the
developing world.
And we've seen that, too.
So yes, it's hard.
And we do focus on it.
So I think in your case,
Olafur, the scaling up is also
a question of distribution.
And that is a huge part
of the challenge, right?
Again, beyond the
functional, the distribution.
Yes, and it's a question of--
we chose them to be
primarily market driven,
even though a lot
of the market driven
projects we're working
on, I-- in fact,
NGO projects has a lot
of NGOs are leaning
towards using market
systems for, let's say,
resource optimization.
The scalability I think--
there was, I think,
what's this story?
The story about the
condoms and HIV.
They were trying
to push out condoms
and it was really difficult. And
they went into the rural areas.
And every time they
brought the condoms, well,
somebody got there before them.
And that was Coca-Cola.
[INAUDIBLE] sort of
makeup and stuff.
How come the makeup got
there before the condoms?
And obviously, it has to do
with this idea of push and pull.
And people who know about market
economy, which I don't, would
know how to facilitate
the push versus the pull.
So pull it like the desires
pulling the Coca-Cola
from the company all the
way out into the areas
where there is not even a road.
But there's plenty of Coca-Cola.
And so the idea is
that the desire locally
seems to be an
incredibly strong force.
And this is why then they change
the campaigning for condoms
from being about
addressing a problem--
the problem of getting
sick and HIV, and so on,
to talk campaigning for--
well, almost campaigning
for promiscuity.
Kind of having fun and more sex.
And then the campaign-- the
kind of a condom campaign
became more successful
like, let's have more sex.
It's great.
And in that sense, we have
learned a lot, I think,
to if we want to go down the
market driven principles.
Because one could also
say, well, maybe thinking
about every fifth
person in this room
would not have access to energy.
Just like all the people
over there and these.
So you have energy,
you don't have energy.
What about just say,
OK, let's just quit it.
Because let's see, isn't it
so that the war in Afghanistan
is like a billion dollar
a week or whatever.
Billion dollar every two
weeks or something like this.
Incredible.
So that's $2 billion, then
everybody-- all these people
have one of these.
So maybe we should
instead of going--
it's going to take
a long time, as I
said, delivering on the lamp's
through the market economy.
And we know market economy can
be pretty dodgy also, right?
It's exploitive
[INAUDIBLE] because--
so, anyway.
So maybe there are other ways.
But for the time being, we
don't have any other ways.
And it does seem to--
there is something
in it when we have
a young group of 30 boys who are
former alumnae program by plan
in Zimbabwe in a city,
which I don't remember now.
And it's a door to
door sales system.
These 30 boys,
they are up to me--
they are making on an
average between $40 and $60
a week each selling this.
So this is by far, the
most successful business
opportunity there have been.
And the funny
thing is, they kind
of importer the wholesale--
the person who imports,
he makes a ton of money.
And we go, OK, can't
you share a little bit?
But, no, no.
We realize we can't start
telling them how to--
what to do and how to
do the business better.
It was very aggressive.
So the market system
proves efficient,
but also a little bit unfair,
and so on and so forth.
This has facilitated
a growing model.
Now there's six other
groups, each with 30
boys between 20 to 25, I think.
Now they are testing
and taking on.
They need a little loan.
We seeds the first lamps,
half the production price.
They send half the money.
A little bit of money.
And the road is
still bumpy but we
are finding successful models.
And unfortunately, we cannot
take that model from Zimbabwe
and apply it on another country.
We have to in a
different country totally
different government, different
system, different tax system.
And you would think that you
could take Zimbabwe and put it
into Zambia.
But you can't.
We haven't been able
to so far, at least.
So yes, the scalability--
this group over there
is a really big--
it's like a close to
impossible challenge
within a short period.
It would be easier to drop them
off with an airplane, which
of course, would have a
lot of other problems.
But basically,
coming to shut down
the [? war ?] one week
before and proceed and so on.
So I want to open the
floor up very soon to you.
But I have one final question.
I think we would be remiss
with the focus of this pairing
without talking a
little bit about design.
And I knew that I was--
contrasting
approaches to design.
And I know Harald
and I were just
talking because he has this
background at Stanford where
he got his--
Masters.
--master's degree in
mechanical engineering.
He also was an IDEO before.
I happened just
a little anecdote
to take three MIT
students, three art
scholars out to Stanford.
We had a big national hackathon
in the D-School there.
The MIT students were so
struck by how different
the approach was.
In Harald we had the MIT
team versus the IDEO approach
and the Stanford approach,
which is kind of different.
All mixed.
Yeah, it's a little mixed.
Right.
And then Olafur,
as an artist, has
thought so much about how
to activate participation
in his works.
And I know the experience of
individuality and collectivity
at the same time is something
that his work in particular,
I think, is really
masterful at creating.
So I just want to see if I
can get you both to address
this approach to design.
Yeah.
Regardless, maybe
even into the product.
But maybe how it's also
affected how you've
created these solar products.
Yeah, so it is true that when
I went to MIT and Stanford
the approaches to teaching
engineering and design
were different.
And I can appreciate that.
So now, at Cooper Perkins,
I'm encouraging our group
to think creatively by
teaching them skills--
drawing skills on the right
hand side of the brain.
And that is helping to think
more laterally rather than
linearly.
Education, especially at MIT and
other universities like that,
tends to be a linear process.
So you can be channeled into
a particular linear approach.
And the broader thinking,
the brainstorming,
all that process,
I think, is what
generates the richness
of ideas in combination
with getting a different
group of people.
Not 20 people all the same,
but 20 people all different
participating in a brainstorming
process and selecting ideas,
I think, is what makes the
design process in that style
much more powerful.
We used that at IDDS.
It's an important ingredient.
We always, when we're
selecting participants,
try to select participants
from different parts
of the world but also
different occupations
so we can put pastors
together with mechanics
and get different
solutions to the problems.
So that kind of lateral
thinking approach
was very heavily
taught at Stanford.
A little bit of
design over there,
as well-- product design.
And as I showed in the
images in the presentation,
it was part of the process
for designing the lamp.
Where we brainstormed and we
came up with configurations
of the light.
And we made little models
of how it might work.
And then decided on the
final form that you see.
And we actually show that
process to the participants
so they can run that
process themselves.
Great.
Thanks.
Olafur.
Yeah, I think for
me, the design is--
how should I say--
applying how onto why.
So if I have sorted out what
I want to do as an idea,
I need to sort of start applying
sort of language onto the idea
so the idea takes
shape or gets a body,
but sort of takes space.
And design is obviously
more than just
wrapping it with some
material and deciding.
But essentially, if the
idea contains this idea
that it has to touch somebody
in one way or the other,
the design would need to
amplify that in a body.
So the design you know
is, I believe, almost
like an amplifier of the
intentionality of the idea.
But having said that, the design
obviously is also more complex
because it's a
part of an economy,
it's a part of the
environment, it's
a part of a lot of other
structures which is outside.
The labor involved
with assembling this,
is that labor done at the
source or can it be applied
later on in the design process?
Could one send the components
and then make a factory
and then at the assembly?
So the design is
also the economy
of the production, both
the economy financially,
but also the economy
of labor and time
and how people devised this.
So I think of design often like
the quality of the language.
And the design's
purpose is to make sure
that what was said
at the beginning
actually comes out at the end.
So the design doesn't sort
of deroot the why on the--
sort of halfway through.
I say this because
I think this also
applies on how I work
when I work as an artist.
And as an artist, I'm obviously
occasionally celebrating
the idea of doing
no good or doing
nonsense or unpredictable
successes, such as improvising
and just--
so I just want to keep
it a little bit open.
The way doesn't have to be
a very sort of pointed why.
It can also be,
OK, let's just not
do something reasonable today.
[INAUDIBLE]
And sometimes there is a lovely
work of art right in there
as well.
If you don't mind me
adding that detail?
No.
I'm glad you did.
So we want to take some
questions from you now.
Please.
Are you trying to see production
of these in the places
where they will be used?
Did you hear that?
So whether I am trying to put
the production into the places
where they use. , Yes we'd very
much like to produce them--
I mean, right now, the solar
panels from California.
The LED is German.
The plastic is also German.
The inside is from Taiwan.
The batteries are Chinese,
and so on and so forth.
But essentially, the
first step, which
we have been looking
into, would be
to do an assembly factory
or sort of assembly place
so we can sort of
ship the components.
And for our next scale,
it would take 15 people
on a sort of assembly type
sort of one space factory.
Very basic.
The challenge here is
that it's not actually
the salary in the
economy and so on.
It would probably make it
even a little bit cheaper,
which is the upside.
The downside is that shipping
green environmentally
friendly certified
product very often
has some tax benefits in it.
This means we can send this
into Nigeria, for instance,
tax free because it goes in
as a sort of green World Bank
certified green
Lighting Africa program,
and so on and so forth.
If we send it as
electronic components,
we have to pay 45% tax on some
of it 25% on some other, 10%
on other.
And this means that that
actually takes the upside away.
It's a very puzzling
how this sort
of environmentally industry
being the good industry
is also having--
but once you hit
a certain scale,
that then turns over again.
And so it's just
a question of time
before it actually
pays off again.
There's a microphone here.
Do we have other questions?
There's one on the
other side as well.
One more.
Yeah.
I haven't had a chance to
look at this very closely,
but what I see here, it looks
like the case is actually
a fairly complex shape.
[INAUDIBLE] plastic
outside case.
And I'm wondering,
what challenges
there were to design
that and keeping
with the [INAUDIBLE] possible?
And whether that's an area where
the injection molding process
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
It sort of looks complex.
But it's actually-- it's a
two-part injection mold system.
So there's a lid and a base.
And then of course,
I made some effort in
to make it a wearable.
Because it does represent
a certain value.
So it's not something you're
likely-- during the charging
in the day, you're not
likely to put it out
if it represents what you would
spend in two months on kerosene
for lighting for a family.
You don't see very often
that you sort of lay it
in the garden and then go
to work and come back and--
so that was one of the
sort of user modes.
The thing is that it actually
has a ventilated system inside.
So some work went into making
sure that when it's in the sun,
it heats up immensely,
especially the black part here.
And this means it has to
take-- it has an air intake.
You can kind of see it.
And an air outtake.
And the flow sort of
wraps around the batteries
and goes out again.
We engineer that quite a
while to keep the battery
from overheating.
Because they don't like--
the batteries are not the
worst batteries you can get,
but these are not
the best batteries
also because they had to be
in a reasonable price range.
The LEDs can't [INAUDIBLE]?
No.
But I mean, we don't
really get up in the area
where the LED-- it's just
because the batteries have--
they have 900 or about
900 recharges to full.
And we would want
to-- heating up
900 times is also quite
a challenge for them.
So we worked a lot on
this little cooling sort
of from Arabic architecture
cooling principle
that the rise of hot air
draws in cooler air and so on.
It only took 3% of--
we did the test.
It only took the heat down 3%,
but just enough for kind of--
at the top of the heat,
that's quite a bit.
[INAUDIBLE]
Well, typically,
when charging, yes.
I mean, we encourage on the--
if we have any input.
We very often actually charges
sort of standing or leaning.
And this means that there
is a bigger likelihood
that it actually has an uptake.
This is also not so bad.
It should also heat like this.
Yeah.
I would add that
the biggest price--
the costly parts of the
light are the internals,
the batteries, the solar cell,
the LED and the circuit board.
And the plastics
are a smaller part.
So you can focus your design
effort on getting the features,
making that product
of high quality.
And it's not that big a penalty
relative to everything else.
So you wouldn't take this
and cut off all of its wings
and come up with a
significantly cheaper product.
It's a good design.
I think we're done.
So onto the next panel.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Good evening, everybody.
We are going to start the
second discussion now.
And now we are going
to take a step back.
Because apart from design
challenges and delivery
challenges, there
are other challenges
behind this technology, which
is the technology itself.
So you have to
design them first.
And there is a lot of
science behind that.
So in the next 40
minutes or so, you'll
probably learn more about
the science of solar cells
than you ever wanted to know.
But we'll try to
make it interesting.
And when I try to
describe the Little Sun
project to my daughter
who is only five,
her first reaction
was, yeah, I know
what you are talking about.
It's like [INAUDIBLE].
First, I laughed.
And then I started thinking
a little bit more about it.
And I thought, that's
a perfect test system
to actually look at different
aspects of any technology.
Now this technology is magic.
We don't really know what kind
of innovation went into it.
But there are
aspects of it which
can be applicable to
any kind of technology.
Now just look at them.
So first one is functionality.
Obviously, you want the
device to work as intended.
Like in this
particular case, it's
supposed to give you a
light when you need it.
Another aspect is stability.
So you want it to
work in the cave,
outside, when it's raining,
when it's not raining,
when it's cold a hot.
So that's stability
of [INAUDIBLE]..
Portability,
obviously, it's nice
if you can put it in
your pocket and take it
with you where you need it.
Efficiency, it's how much energy
you can get out of your device
and how much useless
energy you get.
Like in this
particular case, you
get light, which is
what Frodo needs.
And it doesn't seem that
this device gets really hot
because that would be
unwanted energy, which
would drive efficiency down.
And also it doesn't
have to be beautiful,
but it doesn't hurt
if it's beautiful.
It's all this nice to use
something that looks nice.
So now, let's look
at our technology,
which is photovoltaics.
So the first aspect
is functionality.
So it's supposed to work.
So what does it do?
It converts solar
energy into electricity,
which in turn can be
used to create light
or to make work our electronic
devices which we love so much
and depend so much upon.
So the functionality is
based on sound science.
So how does it work?
That's where it gets scientific.
But don't turn away please.
So although, we usually
talk about light as waves,
actually when a light
interacts with matter--
in this case, it's solar cell--
it reveals its quantum nature.
And what it means,
it actually consists
of a lot of little
particles called photons.
And when those
particles interact
with the material
of the solar cell,
they set free and another type
of particle, which is electron.
So it was sitting quietly
and it's energetically
preferred place in the solar
cell, but now it breaks free
and it can move and it
leaves a hole behind.
And then if we can make
those particles move,
we can collect them into
the electrical circuit
and they will make work.
And work is needed to
make this device work.
OK, so that's how it works.
It obviously, works when
the sun is up and there
is a lot of light in the
summer on a nice cloudless day.
But we also would
like this to work
when the sun is going down,
because you still need
your cell phone then, right?
And also you would like
it to work when it rains
or when it's windy or in any
kind of ambient condition.
In that aspect is portability.
It's also nice if that
is kind of a device
that you can actually
put in your pocket
and take it places where
there is no [INAUDIBLE]..
And as we've heard in the
previous conversation,
that's always that
possibility goes hand in hand
with aesthetics.
Because if you have a huge power
plug somewhere in a desert,
probably people don't really
care how it looks like.
Nobody's going to see it.
But if it's something you
want people to actually
take with them around, you
better make it look nice.
So that's important.
And then we go to
portability also
goes with efficiency, because
the requirements to efficiency
are now more strict.
Because if it's small, you
also want it to be light.
If it's light, that means you
cannot use too much material.
So that's a challenge.
But still, you want to squeeze
as much energy out of it
as possible.
So it's requirements to
efficiency become even stricter
if you are trying to
make something portable.
OK, so what does it
problems with efficiency.
It seems there is so much
sunlight, if it just collect
it and converted into
electrical current,
it shouldn't be a problem.
Well, the problem is not only
light is made out of particles.
It's actually made of
different kinds of particles.
As you know, after rain,
when there is a rainbow,
there are different
colors in light.
And those different
colors are actually
different types of particles--
those photons.
And what is different
is they carry
a different amount of energy.
But there is only
a certain amount
of energy-- quantum
of energy which is
needed to set free an electron.
And every photon can only
set free one electron.
And so then, if you just
look at how much energy
different photons have
different color [INAUDIBLE],,
you see that some of them
actually don't have enough.
So they are totally useless.
They cannot do work for us.
Some of them have too much.
So they do the
work, but they have
excess of energy, which just
ends up heating our solar cell.
And again, it's lost.
So the efficiency is going down.
So that's a challenge.
So what are you
going to do with it?
So it calls for some
material innovations.
So what kind of innovations
you can think of?
So the obvious one is you want
to change your solar cell.
So if you can come up
with solar cell made
of some kind of material
or different materials
or an artificial material
that actually makes
use of all the energy of all
the photons very efficiently,
that would be one solution.
And then another solution
which may sound crazy, but you
can actually change the sun.
Because this sun we have--
that's the only the
one we have, right?
We don't have a choice.
But it generates
all those photons
of different energy, which
seem not to work nicely
with our technology,
which is a PV cell.
So we don't like that.
So what can we do about it?
How can we change sun?
Well, we just need to remember
that heat is actually light
and light is heat.
So we saw that those
unwanted photons,
they generate a lot of
heat, which was a problem.
But we can actually turn
it to our advantage.
Because if you
think of it, our sun
is just a giant ball of burning
gas, which is just heat.
And it generates all those
photons of different energies.
So what if it just absorbs
them into a little sun?
We just make a
tiny artificial sun
which just absorbs the whole
energy of all those photons
and heats up.
But then we design
the sun in such a way
that it only emits good kind
of atoms, just the right size,
which can be used by our
solar cell very efficiently.
Then obviously we have
another material challenge.
Because this sun appears to be
made of some kind of material
which only made those photons.
And those materials have to
be stable at high temperatures
because it's going to be hot.
So there are a lot of
different challenges
in the design of solar cells.
And the next speakers,
Evelyn and Jeffrey,
are going to tell you
about different aspects
of this technology and
challenges they're facing
and what kind of innovations
they come up with to overcome
those challenges.
So I give it to them.
Thanks, [? Sveda, ?] for
the great introduction.
And both Jeff and
my lives easier.
So today, what I'd
like to share with you
is a technology that
we've been working on.
And it's collaborative,
so of course, I
wanted to acknowledge the people
that actually really do it.
My students, Andrej
Lenert and David Bierman,
and my former
postdoc Youngsuk Nam.
As well as our
collaborators who also
a student, Walker
Chan, who works
with Ivan Celanovic, as well
as Marin Soljacic in physics.
And what we've
been working on is
thinking about these kind
of solar thermophotovoltaic
devices.
And I'll talk a little
bit about how this works.
But I think hopefully
from [? Sveda's ?] intro,
you'll see it.
We're harnessing the
sun in the form of heat
to eventually
generate electricity.
So when you typically
think about the sun
in the form of heat and
how you harness that,
you think of solar thermal
approaches such as this power--
these kind of steam
power plant designs.
What you may be familiar
with and you've seen around
are these parabolic
trough type configurations
where you concentrate
the sun, again,
like in the form of heat
to heat up this working
fluid in this tube.
It's usually of oil.
And this oil then drives
the steam cycle, right?
And then the advantage
of this approach,
as [? Sveda ?]
already said, is you
can now collect all of
the different wavelengths
from the sun and use it as
heat to drive the steam engine
and generate electricity.
But typically, these
are much more efficient
at the utility scale.
And there are challenges with
maintenance costs in terms
of these large scale systems.
But there could be
an added advantage,
because one of the challenges
is that you also want to-- you
don't have sun all the time.
And you might want to store some
of this via a thermal method,
such as a thermal
storage, mechanism
such that you can have
continuous electricity
generation-- or
power generation.
So, as [? Sveda ?]
already said, the other
approaches the using
these photovoltaics.
However, only
certain wavelengths
are useful to excite
these charged carriers
to generate electricity.
But the advantage
of this approach
is extremely scalable
for your rooftop
or to larger scale systems.
And they're solid state where
there's no moving parts at all.
And the challenge however,
like I said already,
is that it's very
hard to store energy--
electrical energy.
So when you look at these
two different approaches,
you'd like to think that,
maybe we can combine them
in some way such
that you could take
advantage of the great things
about these technologies.
So if we can try to
harness the full spectrum
of the sun in the
form of heat and we
can make it scalable
and solid-state
and also offer this continuous
opportunity to generate power,
this would be great.
And the opportunity
is using what we call
solar thermal photovoltaics.
And so the idea is you take
a typical configuration
of a photovoltaic cell,
where you collect all of--
you have the sun shining
on this photovoltaic cell,
and instead of
this, in fact, you
have an intermediate
conversion process
where we have this materials of
a selective absorber emitter.
So what we're doing here
is that, again, we're
collecting now
the whole spectrum
of the sun in the form
the heat by absorbing it
with this absorber.
And then we're
transferring this heat
to a high enough
temperature such
that we can target the ideal
wavelengths the PV cell is
actually using these photons.
And using this kind of
design of this emitter,
such that then we can get
efficient power generation.
And so you would think,
well, exactly how
do you go about doing this?
And the reason why we're
thinking about this approach
is that, in fact,
theoretically, you
can get very, very high
efficiencies-- over about 80%
or so.
So the key is in
the materials design
and ultimately, in the
design of this kind
of intermediate converter--
this selective absorber emitter.
And that of also how
you design the PV cell
to match the
temperatures that you
need to thermally
emit to what, we
call, the band gap
of the PV cell.
So to give you a little
bit of perspective
though, because we're looking
at particular wavelengths,
in fact, this emission--
this thermal mission
has to be at very
high temperatures.
Usually, on the order of
about 1,000 degrees Celsius.
So how do we do this?
So I just gave a schematic
of the technology
that we're really focused on.
We're looking at this
planar setup, just here.
So the sun comes in here.
We can concentrate the sun so
we can get it hotter and hotter.
This absorber emitter could be a
higher and higher temperatures,
because that's what we need.
And so we absorb this total
spectrum of the solar radiation
using these carbon nanotubes.
It turns out the
reason we're using
these kind of carbon
nanotubes structures,
is they're very good absorbers.
They're almost near the
ideal perfect absorber
of a black body absorber.
So you could see that
absorbtivity is close to 1,
in this case.
So we're really trying to
absorb as much as possible.
And meanwhile, as
I said, then you
can get it high enough
temperature so that then you
can try to tailor the emission
close to the band gap of the PV
cell.
And in this case, we've been
working with our collaborators
where they've been designing
these one-dimensional photonic
crystals which consist of
these different layered stacks
of silicon and
silicon dioxide films.
And that way, we can get
constructive interference such
that you can emit close to
this ideal kind of a band
gap of the PV cell.
And of course, there
are tricks to this.
And I'll just-- won't go
on too many the subtleties.
But in fact, you
can see here that we
placed the carbon
nanotubes selectively
in this particular area
of the total area--
the active area.
And the reason we do
this is, in fact, you
may recall from
some maybe physics
lectures that we have
very good absorbtivity,
you also have great emissivity.
And we have to high emissivity,
you lose all the heat too.
So we've actually done a
geometric type configuration
to help us with
this problem where
if we now change that
area ratio between what's
the active area of this
emitter compared to that
of the absorber and we
coat the rest of this
with a very low emissivity
material, essentially,
what kind of change the
energy balance of the system.
So we can really
maximize absorption
if we get to higher and
higher levels of input power
from the solar lights.
We have to concentrate
it at higher levels.
And this way, then we
can actually really
improve the efficiency
of the absorption process
while minimizing some
of this emission.
So these are the
kinds of materials
that we're working with.
And so far, we've demonstrated
three to four times higher
efficiency that
has been reported.
It's about 3% to 4%
efficiency overall,
which is relatively low still.
But with our work, we've
shown that if we just
make the system slightly
bigger, then in fact,
you can reach 20% conversion
efficiencies, which
make them comparable
to solar cells, which
is the one that everyone's
talking about now.
And there's, again, the
theoretical potential
is much higher.
So I thought I'd just show you
a video of some of these images
that were taken from our
media hope and the MIT
mechanical design
department John Frita.
Just give you a
little perspective
of what the system looks
like when it's operating.
I lost my cursor.
Let me play this.
OK, here we go.
So this is actually looking
front down onto the absorber.
This is another example of these
carbon nanotubes absorbers.
And this is your PV cell.
We're placing it on top in
this planar or system here.
It sopped playing.
Whoops.
I'm not sure why it stopped.
Oh, thank you.
OK, so here's absorbers.
So this is kind of
looking in from the--
from the perspective of the sun.
And here is another example.
And you can see us placing
it close to the PV cell.
And here is when we
start to open the shutter
to have our simulated solar
spectrum onto our device.
And you can see now
that it's glowing
hot, which indicate that it's
at very high temperatures.
And that's where it's
emitting to the PV cell.
And so just gives you a
little bit of perspective
as to the types of
experiments that we're
doing to help
realize and develop
materials that can
help us kind of realize
the potential of
this technology.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, how's everybody doing?
Good?
OK.
Hi, I'm Jeff.
I am here to tell
you about a project
that we're working on that's
trying to make solar PV 3D.
And I thought I'd start by
handing some things out.
And actually, I thought you
might be interested in what
a solar cell-- what the active
part of the solar cell is.
What's the part that's
doing all the work?
So I have that here.
And this way, you don't
have to take apart and break
your Little Suns.
But this is it.
This is what's inside
of your solar cell.
This is what's
doing all the work.
And then everything else is
just sort of encapsulation.
And you can see that
I just broke it.
And that's fine.
I want you to break this.
I'm going to hand this around.
Breaking things
is a great thing.
Touch it, feel it, break it.
I tell my students--
I tell my kids and my
students, you learn best
by picking yourself up.
So break stuff, make mistakes.
I'm passing this
around just so you
can feel what the solar
cell actually is like.
That's actually mostly
silicon, which is just sand
that we've put a lot of energy
into to make into silicon.
So that's what
we're all the cost
is in terms of material
that's in there.
And then here's what the
final solar cell looks like.
So I'm going to
hand this out too.
You'll notice this weighs a lot
more because it's encapsulated,
which is something you
need to do to give it
the 0-year lifetime that you get
if you go to, say, Home Depot.
First of all, can
anybody guess where
I bought that solar panel?
That one their.
Best price you get for
those solar panels.
Any guess?
eBay, you bet.
You bet.
If you want to buy solar panels
that you can break or make
into functional
panels, go to eBay.
It's better prices than China.
This is actually-- actually,
they come from China and then--
anyway.
This is what has
when you encapsulate.
What do you notice about
these panels though?
There's one thing I
want you to notice.
There's a hint in the title.
They're flat.
But that's not optimal.
In fact, if you
just look around,
nature does not collect
sunlight in a flat manner.
The tops of trees are not flat.
Now, that's not necessarily
the best example
because trees are designing and
optimizing around many factors,
like survival, water
distribution, weight
and so forth.
But solar cells--
solar collection--
you can pass this
around, break it.
Do whatever you want.
Take it home.
Seriously.
They're flat and they
don't need to be.
And that's not optimal.
So how do you go
three dimensional?
What would happen?
Well that's the
question we asked.
And you wouldn't have
asked this a little while
ago because the materials cost
dominated over the installation
costs.
That's no longer true.
So now you can ask
questions like,
what happens if we
waste a little material
but go 3D, for example?
So it turns out that it's
very easy to compute.
If you had, say, five flat
panels like that laid out flat
and you want to compute
how much energy you
get from that in
the day depending
on when and where you are in the
world, that's easy to compute.
But what if you just fold it up?
That's easy.
What if you just fold
them up and make a cube?
That's actually not
easy to compute.
And really, people
haven't thought about this
because again, the
materials costs would
have killed you 10 years ago.
Won't anymore.
So the question is, first of
all, what is the best 3D shape
for a solar panel if you go 3D?
And that was the first
question we wanted to ask.
And we found all sorts
of beautiful designs
that we thought, well, what
if we just try some of these?
But then we thought, let's
be a little smarter about it.
We're engineers, so
let's engineer this.
And what we did is
we built actually
a really cool
simulation that's based
on the properties of evolution.
So it actually using something
called a genetic algorithm.
It can take any random
assortment-- any random 3D
shape, and you can tell it
where you are and when you are.
And it'll give you
an emergent order.
And it'll tell you what
the optimal structure
for that given location should
be if you were to go 3D.
How do you maximize the power?
So that was kind of cool.
And then we said, well, OK,
that's just a simulation.
How about let's build it.
And so as Olafur mentioned,
we don't actually
think too much about design.
So we first built this.
And we said, well, this
looks like pretty good to us.
And then we went to our
architecture friends
and they said, no, no, no.
That doesn't look good at all.
You need to do this.
And then we said, well, we
can't buy solar panels that
look like this.
So we sort of compromised
and we had some iterations.
And we were now-- and please,
take these, break them.
Do what you want.
These are just these-- there
are just to touch and feel it.
This is 3D PV.
So we built these, we put them
on the rooftop of our building
and we measured data.
And here's the sun going
across one of these 3D panels.
You can see sometimes
you're wasting panels.
And here, you're absorbing, and
then it changes during the day.
But one thing that's
really interesting,
well, we put these on the
rooftop of our building
to do the testing.
And I'll tell you, I just
moved here from California.
And all the simulations
were for sun only.
Because it's easy to do sun
only, it's hard to do clouds.
And we just needed one
sunny day, just one.
And it was really frustrating
because it took two weeks
to get that in Boston.
And I'm looking at
the California weather
on my phone every day, all sun.
But actually, it
was really cool.
Because what happened is
the bad weather of Boston
actually helped
us learn something
really cool about going 3D
that we had not predicted,
which is that it's actually
better on cloudy days.
Because when you go 3D you take
advantage of scattered light--
of diffuse light.
Can't do that when you're 2D.
So that was really
cool actually.
And I thank the Boston weather.
So anyway we tested it and
some cool things happen.
So if you look at the power
you can generate versus height,
it's linear with height.
So if you have a
confined base area,
you know that you can
just keep going up.
That makes sense
because now you're
collecting light when the sun
is shining kind of on the side.
And so you go higher up, you're
going to collect more light.
What's also interesting
is the worst time of day
is noon for the same reason.
Right when the sun
is overhead, you
do worse than as the sun kind
of goes down around the edges.
But what's cool-- so
this is a flat panel
and this is the power
you get during the day.
That's the typical
power curve for a day.
And if you look at
that, you got about 5,
5 and 1/2 hours of
usable electricity.
If you dual access
track a solar cell,
you can get up to
eight because you
can go much higher
because you're now
tracking the sun each day.
But we don't do that
because it's moving parts
on your rooftop and that breaks
and it costs a lot of money.
So it's not cost effective.
With 3D, built into
the structure--
because you've wasted
a little material.
Built into the structure,
you have the eight hours.
Because now, you're
always sort of generating
a constant amount of power
no matter where the sun is.
And we can actually
optimize for that.
We didn't even try
to optimize for that
in this particular case.
So this is sort of what
we've been excited about.
And we talked to
different people
about where we could try to
work with this kind of thing.
And one of the first interesting
opportunities that came out
was--
by the way, we
still have not been
able to build a panel like this.
But we're thinking about it--
is e-bikes.
So there's this nice
architecture's rendition
of a charging station where
you have area confined--
you have a limitation
in your area.
You don't want to
put solar panels
across this beautiful square.
But maybe if you
put a tower that's
been optimized in
the right way, you
could charge say
30-40 bikes a day.
Now, we think, e-bikes.
Who uses e-bikes, right?
Well 120 million
of them in China.
So there are places, not the
US, where e-bikes are used.
And there are some universities,
like the University
of Washington where
actually they've
shown that if you force
e-bikes onto students,
you get much less traffic
problems in your campus.
Much less parking problems too.
So that's one area
that we're looking at.
We're looking at other designs.
And then we thought-- the last
thing I'll say and I'll stop,
is we thought, well, these
designs are kind of hard.
We've made some that
actually are foldable.
So you ship them flat and you
crank them and you can go 3D.
But it's still hard
because you need
to have a base
that can handle it.
You need to build the base.
You need to build
the base and you
need to build the structure.
And it needs to be
weather resistant and all
of these things.
And so then we started
thinking, well, wait a second.
The world has a 3D
landscape already.
It's called houses.
It's called buildings.
So we started
thinking, well, what
if we couldn't optimize
the structure itself
as we did here?
But what if we could
take the landscape
that we have available to
us and optimize around that?
So we've been looking
at things like, we
can take all the
rooftops from Google
and we can actually
3D print them.
So we can 3D print
a neighborhood.
And then we can
think about how--
let's say, if a city
block in Cambridge
all calls Home Depot today
and says, I want solar panels,
every house will get their
panels perfectly aligned
for the house.
But the question
is, what happens
if the houses work together?
What are the collective effects?
Could a neighborhood do
better by working together.
And the answer is absolutely.
So we've done the simulations.
And I have a fun
little tw0-house
demo here that I don't
have time to show you.
But you guys should come up
and play with that afterwards
and break it.
Touch it, feel it,
measure currents
and you'll see that by
going 3D, you can actually
open up possibilities.
Where you never would have
installed panels before,
you can now install
panels because you're
using the neighboring house
to help you get sunlight.
Mirrors are cheap.
Whether anyone wants to
put mirrors on their house
is another question.
But anyway, OK, so
I'll stop there.
And I think we take
questions now, right?
What do we do?
We Sit down.
We sit down.
OK, thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, I was over time.
You didn't see that.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, guys, I was thinking
about innovations.
And innovations
are made by people.
They don't just come
out by themselves.
So I have two people right here.
So if you would like
to share something--
Why-- You're are in mechanical
engineering, both of you,
right?
I'm material science.
I'm sorry.
Recovering physicist.
Right.
Yeah, so why are you interested
in this kind of solar energy
projects?
And is it more interesting
than other things you are doing
or how it compares?
And so why?
You want me to
answer that first?
I'd be happy to.
OK.
Are you asking where the
ideas come from or are you
asking why I am--
What motivates
you, why you think
it's more interesting than
something else in material
science?
There are different problems
in material science.
This is true.
So what drives me, what keeps
me up at night is the following.
So if you look at sort of
clean energy technology,
and clean water fits into that.
I'd like to say water is
the only energy problem you
can actually die from.
But anyway, because
they're closely coupled.
But these are problems that
actually the solution to which
will be based on a choice of
material or choice of design.
Now, what's
interesting about that
is that's very different
than previous revolutions
that we've had.
So how many of you
know how many steps
go into making a
chip in your phone?
How many elements are
even in your phone?
Does anybody know?
Elements from the
periodic table.
Take a guess.
30?
Good guess.
How many?
It's actually higher.
43.
Excellent guess.
It's actually 62.
62 elements are in this phone.
There are only about 90
that you have to work with.
But the thing is that
what's interesting about it,
if you ask how many
steps are there process--
how many steps are there to
make a chip in the phone?
Any guesses?
It's almost 1,000.
It's around 1,000.
But of those how many
have a choice in material?
How many have had a choice of
material for the last 50 years?
It's about 10.
So this revolution here
that we all know and love,
this is a processing revolution.
This is not a
materials revolution.
This is not.
It's also a design
revolution, clearly.
But the future of energy will
be a materials revolution.
Because all the
bottlenecks in energy
are essentially based
on a choice of material.
That's how we're going
to get the efficiency up
and the costs down.
And so that,
combined with design,
is what's going to be
the next revolution.
That's what gets
me really excited.
As a material scientist,
I get excited.
As a mechanical engineer--
[LAUGHTER]
Uh-oh.
I would agree with Jeff here.
Because I think
the opportunities
are at this intersection of
materials and engineering.
We, as you probably
saw from the slides
that I showed, that indeed
we do take advantage
of a lot of the materials.
And a lot of these
materials, we don't actually
create or invent ourselves.
We rely on material scientists
to help us kind of come up
with them.
And then we get
excited about them
because now we can
realize new properties.
And I think that's
really the opportunity.
To be able to tune the
spectral properties.
To be able to
collect wavelengths
in certain at
particular wavelengths
and not collect them and others.
To be able to now effectively
transport the heat.
Say, have better thermal
conductors or better insulators
in certain regions, which
are critical in these kinds
of devices are, I think,
the opportunities.
And then being able to
then manipulate them
and integrate them into device.
So it's really this
interplay, I think,
that is really exciting
about-- especially
now that we are facing
these energy problems.
And now, we're in a
well-positioned time
in being able to
now control them
in a way-- control
the materials,
create them in a way.
And I think that's where
the opportunities are too.
OK, staying on the
people subject,
you guys don't actually do work.
Your students do
it-- your postdocs.
So when new students
come, does it
feel like more people are
now interested in doing
energy kind of science or less?
Is it a lot of interest
in new generation?
Could I just say, the phrase
we don't actually do work
is a little troubling.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't mean it.
But anyway, yeah, we're
not in the lab as much.
Let's put it that way.
It's a collective effort.
But yes, the students are
the ones in the trenches.
And they do-- yeah, they
deserve all the credit.
So there is an enormous
amount of energy in energy
on the part of the students.
In fact, I think
really if you want
to look at what the problem
is, is the problem is
there isn't enough funding.
There aren't enough resources.
So there is much more pent
up demand and excitement
on trying to solve these
energy problems that I
see than there are spots
available for students
to work on them.
That's really the issue here.
And this is a long-term problem.
That's part of the issue.
This is nothing-- this will
not be solved in 18 months.
This will not be solved
in three to five years.
So all of a sudden, the
investment part of this
starts to feel uneasy.
So VCs get a little uneasy
when you talk about that.
But if you want to be honest
about it, it's long term.
You should look at this
as a long-term problem.
So how do we invest in that?
Well, usually, it's
the government that
invests in long-term problems.
Government funding for
energy is very, very little.
Very little.
So indeed, I think we do get
a lot of interest in energy.
Because I think there's also
been a lot of media about it
more and more.
And specifically,
solar has gotten
a lot of renewed interest.
But a lot of students
come in and they
say they want to do energy.
And the reality is,
I think, we have been
doing energy for a long time.
It's just maybe not in
that same words maybe.
And I think a lot of the
fundamental principles
that some of the governing
physics that we've
been talking about
for decades now
can still be kind of used in the
same sense for energy problems.
And so I think there are still--
and certainly as Jeff
already said, that right now,
funding is still low.
And as a professor
where you're always
trying to get funding
to write grants,
you always try to maneuver
in a way to sell your ideas,
whether it's energy right now.
But the idea is
that hopefully, we
can create new capabilities,
new characterization
tools and new ways to
fabricate materials
so that we can understand and
develop new insights into kind
of fundamental principles that
we haven't discovered before.
And then really to take it and
address these really bigger
energy challenges.
There aren't solutions
near-term necessarily.
And so I kind of see that
as an opportunity in the way
we kind of don't think
about more fundamental kind
of science problems that we
can now also further pursue.
And eventually, maybe help
us in the longer term.
Speaking about longer
term-- and I completely
agree that it takes time.
All the innovation takes time.
But it's also uneven.
Sometimes it moves fast,
sometimes for a long time,
it seems to be not
moving where you want it.
So how do you feel photovoltaics
and general solar energy
science?
At what stage is it now?
Is it going to leap
somewhere in the near future?
Or is it going to--
maybe it will be
nice type of leap,
like in terms of
design or delivery
to places where it's needed.
First of all, I think we
should go to questions soon.
But second of all, just a
very quick answer to that.
You can't predict when
breakthroughs will occur.
What you can't predict
is if you don't support
an environment that has the
potential to breakthroughs,
then they won't occur.
So that's for sure.
But innovation,
ideas, creativity,
that usually happens at
intersections that you cannot
predict.
If you tour the Pixar
building-- or it
used to be the Pixar building.
Now it's like it's the Disney
building in Emeryville,
California, they'll
tell you the story
about how Steve Jobs
insisted on one line--
one bathroom in on one floor.
There's a 1,000 people
in this building.
One bathroom.
He insisted for four months
that there could only
be one bathroom.
Why?
The best ideas happen
while waiting in line
next to somebody you don't know.
And they tell the
story passionately.
And then they say
they compromised
because they built this
beautiful atrium for people
to intersect.
But you just don't know.
And so you have to create
an environment that
allows for those intersections
to happen so that you
can get those breakthroughs.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I'm calling on people and
I shouldn't be doing that.
[INAUDIBLE] Let's
take questions.
In the first presentation, how
hot does the intermediate layer
get?
[INAUDIBLE]
My presentation?
How hot does the
intermediate layer get?
This is my presentation?
Oh, it's going to be
about 1,000 degrees,
even for a kind of, what they
call, low-band gap PV cell.
Is that Fahrenheit or Celsius?
Celsius.
So it is very high temperature.
Because it's a thermal
emission process,
so it really has to really
get to high temperatures.
And that is the challenge.
When you were talking about the
inefficiency of photovoltaic
[INAUDIBLE] related to
the wavelengths that
are not being absorved, and then
went on to the 3D presentation.
I'm [INAUDIBLE]
thinking that you
were going start [INAUDIBLE]
nanomaterials and [INAUDIBLE]
surfaces and things
like that, where
[INAUDIBLE] inside
the cores [INAUDIBLE]
wavelengths penetrate
[INAUDIBLE]..
Is there any work in that
direction [INAUDIBLE]??
Is that a question for--
I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
[INAUDIBLE]
I think there's a lot of--
there are a lot of
interesting things
you can do by
nanostructuring materials.
And nano has a
little bit of in--
a way, a bad rap.
It got it got, I think,
a little overhyped.
And of course, Spider-Man--
well, anyway, Incredible Hulk.
We've got all this like
nano in Hollywood and stuff.
But the fact of the matter
is that we can actually
design materials down to
the scale of the atom.
Pretty controllable and in some
ways, depending, at low costs.
And that has opened up all
kinds of opportunities.
Actually, solar cells
are always textured
at that scale on the surface.
You do that on purpose,
because you collect more light.
So at that scale
solar cells always
have that kind of texturing.
Evelyn, I don't know
if you want to--
Well, certainly, I
think you're referring
to-- and people I've been
studying like butterfly wings,
like you said.
These are kind of natural
photonic structures.
And so we're exactly doing that.
We're trying to create now
artificial photonic structures.
I'm not doing it.
My collaborator is.
But they're really designing
it such that in a way
that they can
efficiently kind of
suppress particular
wavelengths and absorb and emit
particular wavelengths,
things like that.
So certainly, you could do
that [INAUDIBLE] structure.
And certainly, that
is an area that
has received a lot of interest.
Jeff, it's broken.
Love it.
[LAUGHTER]
Mission accomplished.
That's good.
Somebody learned something
when they did this.
And that's all I care about
is the learning moments
you create.
Pick yourself up
and move forward.
[INAUDIBLE]
For these kinds of things?
Actually, yeah.
So all of our-- we have
a whole neighborhood
we printed that's
from Cambridge.
And there are two
houses over there.
And so now, we have actually
thought about this--
about 3D printing the cells
directly into the material.
There are some tricky things
you have to do because--
so these are silicon.
I'm guessing the ones
in Little Sun are
either [INAUDIBLE] or silicon.
I'm not sure.
But there are polymer-based
or organic-based materials
that you can 3D
print more easily.
You're not going to
3D print silicon.
So that's something
we've thought about.
The problem there
is, then you have
this issue that those
types of solar cells
tend to be lower efficiency and
they tend to degrade over time.
And so you have packaging
problems and so forth.
But I think it's a
very interesting idea
to directly 3D print the
active layer into the design.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
In terms of the [INAUDIBLE]
size or [INAUDIBLE]..
So in this case,
what we've created
is kind of a layered
stack of films.
And certainly, there are other
types of photonic crystal type
structures that you can make.
And our collaborators
have been working
on these two-dimensional
photonic crystals, which
is I think what
you're referring to
with these kind of
poor geometries.
[INAUDIBLE] geometry
[INAUDIBLE]..
Oh.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, so right now, you're
talking about the absorber?
OK, sorry.
I was confused.
Our active area is
about one centimeter.
And so what we're
trying to do is
we're working with nanotubes
on the order of 100
nanometers in diameter each.
But of course, we're trying
to pattern into an area.
And so when we
shrink the area, we
can get to much
higher concentrations
and also get higher
efficiencies.
So to the areas
that we've shrunk,
we've gone down to about an
area ratio of about seven,
I believe.
So it's about over one
centimeter squared area.
So that's a kind of area
that we're looking at.
But we're kind of not
necessarily, I guess--
as you get smaller and
smaller it's really
a matter of how
much input power you
have to get to get a
higher thermal efficiency.
Because of the fact that
you have to still get
to those 1,000
degree temperatures
to emit this particular--
at the wavelengths
that you want for
the solar cell.
So it's really a matter
of how much concentration
you want really in
a practical system.
Because we know actually one of
the big challenges with solar
is a lot of these
systems are concentrated.
And the optics really
dominate the cost.
And to be realistic,
what we're looking at
is a really small area.
It's really kind of what
we can do in the lab.
And in these kind
of thermal systems,
as you get to bigger
and bigger areas,
you minimize a lot
of the losses--
the parasitic losses that you
would have because now you
have a much more active
area compared to the losses,
say, on the edges or
something like that.
So then hopefully, also
when we have more of that,
then we can also
tailor it better
so we don't have to go to as
high concentrations either.
So then we can
deal with smaller--
if we design it with
these carbon nanotubes,
we can think about how we
design the area of that.
It's not really a question.
It was just [INAUDIBLE]
and he went home and broke.
And that led to him--
and clearly broke it to--
I don't think [INAUDIBLE]
broke it to see what's inside.
That led to
[INAUDIBLE] putting us
into a research program
on his philanthropic work
on environmental questions.
So we [INAUDIBLE]
new [INAUDIBLE]
funding door opening
because of breaking stuff.
I love it.
[LAUGHTER]
That is such a great--
we start a freshman class--
a new class this fall
in our department.
And what we said is--
there's just 12 freshmen.
And we said, think about
what you're passionate about.
So the first day, one kid's
passionate about tennis,
another kid's passion about
octopus and how they camouflage
and so forth.
So the next time, we
brought these things in
and we broke them.
We smashed the
handle of a racket.
And then we analyzed them.
I mean, you talk about
learning moments.
You talk about opportunities
for intersections.
You talk about creativity.
It happens so much
when you break things.
You learn the most when
you pick yourself up.
I mean, let's hope that's
true for the Celtics at least.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
We have time for
one more question.
[INAUDIBLE]
So yeah, I have a question on
the shapes that you generated.
[INAUDIBLE] really interesting
shapes, especially the last one
that was evolutionary.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] And then you went on
to talk about how [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] What is the
difference between this and the
[INAUDIBLE].
Well, and that's
where the engineering
tries to connect with the
art and the architecture.
So the code doesn't
know about aesthetics.
It just tells us what
is the most efficient.
But what it can also do is
it can tell us how well we
do with anything else.
So we actually
purposefully developed
a sort of a way for
the architectures
to put their designs
directly into our code
and see how far off they are.
And it's very interesting
because some of them
are very far off.
But then you do this sort
of double helix type-- well,
it's not a double helix, but
this double spiral thing.
It was only 10% worse.
So that's something that we
would probably tolerate because
of how much nicer it looks.
And so that's an
excellent point.
And there's wiggle room there.
You don't have to be the
most efficient or the top.
You just you want
to find the balance.
Yeah.
All right so I'm
going to get started.
My name is Kyle Barker.
And I'm a recent graduate of the
Master of Architecture program
here at MIT.
So I'll be introducing
our final set of speakers.
We're going to run this one
like the lightning round.
So we have two people speaking
tonight, Professor Sheila
Kennedy and Professor
Karen Gleason.
And we'll be looking
at solar applications.
So how solar technology
is being developed now
and how we're seeing it
to be used in the future.
So I'm going to make very short
introductions of our speakers.
Both of them have bios
of their websites.
And for brevity, I'm just going
to give you the high points.
So Professor Sheila
Kennedy is a Professor
of the Practice at MIT.
Previously, she's taught
at Harvard's Graduate
School of Design and the
University of Michigan.
Sheila has a firm called Kennedy
and Violich Architecture,
which she founded in 1990 with
her partner Frano Violich.
And within KVA, Sheila
founded MATx, which I'll
speak to in her presentation.
So I'll leave that to her.
And then second, we have
Professor Karen Gleason.
Professor Gleason is the
Alexander and I Michael Caster
Professor of Chemical
Engineering at MIT.
And she has also had
teaching appointments
of many other institutions,
which I'll skip for brevity.
She has over 200
published academic papers
and a dozen patents.
So I'll hand it over to, Sheila.
Hi, everybody.
Holding up OK?
That's good.
So I want to just take a
very brief amount of time
and talk about
what we can do now.
How we can take some of
these ideas about materials
and some sort of really
interesting problems
and work with them today.
And so my contact is
there, as Kyle said.
If you're interested, I'd
love to hear from you.
So a problem that
really is interesting
is originated with
this comment that--
oh.
OK.
Andrew.
Where's are-- click here.
OK.
Good.
Paul Farmer was at a
conference several years ago.
And it was a conference
similar to this.
We were talking about
scaling up and how
do you reach out
to people and how
do you mass produce things
and make them really cheap?
And Paul stood up
and he said, wait.
Market forces rarely serve
the needs of my clients.
And Paul is a pioneer
in health care.
And by that, he meant it
in the developing world,
if you're really ill,
you don't want to hear,
I have a super cheap pill.
You want to hear, I
have a life saving pill.
And it's important
to you and I want
to put the best
things for my health.
So Paul really got me thinking
about the market and market
forces.
How do we really rethink the
problem of scale thinking
about new materials?
So just three
points really quick.
The first is to go soft.
How can we use less material?
How can we have a
smaller carbon footprint?
What kinds of
materials can we use?
Because materials equal
energy, as Jeff said.
The energy that goes into making
materials, into heating them,
into forming them.
And into to shipping them
all around the world.
So if you think about the world
and you think about the way
that we're doing things, it's
really like since World War II.
We centralized productions.
We make one thing and
we make it really well.
And we make a lot of it.
And then it gets cheaper.
And then we spend
a lot of carbon
shipping it all
around the world.
So we're trying
to think about how
we can kind of aggregate scales
and how we can sort of change
this paradigm.
So what I'm working with in
the Portable Light Project
is a flexible solar
material, which you see here.
It's a SIGS material.
It's a market-based material.
You can buy it today.
And we're really trying to
take all most of the hard parts
of a lighting kit
and remove them
so that we can just take this
kit and get it into shape,
fold it up.
And then take this
very bright LED light,
which is actually a
little almost too bright,
and create a lantern.
Like a soft lantern.
So that's the premise.
It's very simple.
And we're thinking about
that and developing that.
So it's a kit.
It's an adaptable kit.
And so those are
the parts inside.
The LED, the flexible panel.
A little battery pack.
Of course, not
everything is soft.
You can see the hard
battery underneath here.
We can scale this.
We can add panels.
We can charge multiple things.
We start creating some economy.
And that leads to the kind
of second principle, which
is that people have
a lot of knowledge.
And in so many cultures
around the world,
people have a very direct
connection to textiles.
And so we found that by
dematerializing solar energy
and trying to turn it as much
as possible into a problem
about textiles and
reflectivity, we
can really draw on
local knowledge.
Which is good because it
creates jobs for people
and that's good.
But even more than
that, it creates a sense
of stewardship for energy.
When people are invested
in making something--
and this pattern was actually
made by women in a favela group
called Copa Hoca.
When people make something,
they feel like they own it.
That's the cool
thing about making.
So in the different places where
a portable light has worked,
we work with these
different skill sets.
This is a weaver in the
Sierra Madre mountains
who actually made a little
kit which looks like this.
That's actually the lead
over there on the right.
And then sometimes you
don't have a single producer
making something, because that's
not the best way or the way
that people work.
Because people like
to work together.
So we've developed
a kind of a model
where a one group-- one
community-- here the women
of Copa Roca in Rio de Janeiro.
And then here are another
set of benefactors,
completely in the North
of Brazil in the Amazon.
So you have two groups that
benefit in making things.
And then last, that kind
of adaptable principal.
Like, be as flexible
as possible.
When you have a
flexible solar material,
can the whole kit be adaptable?
Can you actually use something
like this as a lantern?
Can you then be able to take
it in a different position,
walk with it, take it outside
and use it in different areas?
Because more often than
not, people need two things.
They need an ambient
lighting system
and they need a task
lighting system.
So we're trying to
think about that.
So we are developing
really a kind
of a shapeshifting
technology, if you will.
This is sort of the
opposite of a brand.
It's kind of above a brand.
Where you actually don't
see the technology and you
see glimpses of the
same kinds of things.
You might recognize one or
two panels in these kits.
But different textile
configurations
that change the shape
and adapt it to the skill
sets in local cultures and also,
the need of local cultures.
So we can, for example, look at
what this looks like in Mexico,
in Kenya.
You have tailors
who have designers.
So they're putting that in bags.
That's our flat bag,
flexible light and power.
In Nicaragua, a little bit
different kind of design.
Different kind of use.
People charge as they walk
up and down the beach.
And then at night, they
protect turtle eggs
and they get paid by
conservation agencies
to do that.
So that's another
source of income.
And in Brazil, the
development that we're
moving to of actually
using natural materials
and using disposable
degradable materials.
So I'm going to just show you
a very short video that's going
to take my last minute up.
And it's from the Portable
Light Project in Brazil.
And it was actually--
I think you'll like this
because it was actually--
it's sort of the opposite
of a super produced video.
And then it was
shot in large part
with handheld cell phone video
footage that was actually
powered by portable light.
And there was a little bit
that was done by our partners.
It's in Portuguese, so
I hope you won't mind.
I think you'll understand it.
So this shows the context
of Portable Light in Brazil,
where we are nationalizing
this technology
and trying to put it in
many different small river
towns in the Amazon.
So I'll play the video now.
There should be some sound.
Yeah.
So this was their
idea, put music to it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
So we're working mostly
in the Rio [INAUDIBLE]..
This is a typical village there.
- [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
All of these towns are
Portable Light towns.
- [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
[END PLAYBACK]
All right, that's it.
Thank you.
I'll stop it here.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, there is
benefits going last.
I've had such
great introductions
for this technology.
And what my group has done
over the past couple of years
is actually decided
to make solar cells
on paper substrates.
And you may wonder why that is.
We saw the great prop that
Jeff was passing around.
And it had a lot of weight in it
because of the two glass panels
that encapsulate the solar cell.
So obviously, a paper
will be lighter weight.
It will also be a lot cheaper.
If you think about
design, the real reason
that solar is not adopted more
is it's just too expensive.
And so for solar
to be attractive,
you need to be able to hit
a price point of about $140
per meter squared.
And a meter squared
of glass cost $40.
So you've already used
up $80 of your budget.
So I need some other substrate.
I could think about
using plastic.
But in many cases,
plastic for electronics
is actually more
expensive than glass.
Because you can't
use the plastic
that's rough like Coke bottles.
You need to use special
material from DuPont,
which is ultra thin.
When they made a Kindle
using a plastic display,
it ended up costing $1,200.
So we decided to go with paper.
And this requires us to
have processes that work
with the rough substrates
that represent paper and also
the low temperatures.
So what you see here are
actually a 3D solar cell.
This one's in the form
of a paper airplane.
And there's a YouTube
video if you'd
like to look at it that shows
us folding it up and running it.
We like to think about paper
as maybe being delicate.
But we can actually run paper
solar cells under water.
And one of the wonderful things
about this technology, it
really is an intersection
of disciplines.
I'm in chemical engineering.
So I really think mostly
about molecules and processes.
And my collaborator in
electrical engineering,
Vladimir Bulavich
is really an expert
in organic devices
and their properties.
So we put those two together.
We had a fantastic
group of students.
Myles Clark Bar won the Student
Lemelson prize for inventors.
Christopher Voice is now a
Gates Fellow at Cambridge.
And Sungyak Bihn is
a professor in Korea.
And it goes on and on.
So really a lot of
people contributed
to this particular effort.
So how is it that you can
make a solar cell on paper?
Well, you need low
temperature processes.
And we call the one that we
invented in our lab vapor
printing.
And it's analogous
to things that people
use to build cell
phones and laptops,
except we're doing
organic materials.
And we paid particular
attention to the chemistry
so that we could do
it at low temperature.
And we get many things at once.
We put the paper in the reactor.
And we basically
sublimate or turn
into gas vapor reactants
or solid reactants.
And we put a mask in
front of the paper.
And we get exactly the
design that we want.
And if you look at one of the
masked areas at the top here,
you look at the
close up, you can
see the uncoated paper has
this rough fibrous structure.
And when we have the vapor
printing, what you see
is that you still
see that structure.
So you're basically shrink
wrapping each of those fibers,
making a very adherent surface.
So this gives you
durability in what
you're doing so that your
device doesn't delaminate.
And what we vapor
printed here is actually
a transparent electrode.
So it's going to be able to let
the light into the active part
of the device.
The other great thing about
doing something on paper
is that you can do what's
called roll to roll processing.
And so this is analogous
to how newspapers are made.
And it's a much
more economical way
to do solar cell manufacture.
You can imagine that
you really can't roll
to roll process silicon wafers.
And that's one of
the benefits of going
to flexible substrates.
So here's how it works.
We actually have a paper mask.
This was made with a
conventional stencil cutter
like you would use
for a hobby shop.
And you put that mask on top
of a piece of tracing paper,
it goes upside down
in the reactor.
And out comes your piece of
tracing paper with 250 bricks.
And these are electrically
conductive bricks.
And we can do this on a variety
of papers and also textiles.
There's a t-shirt fabric,
stretchable rubber.
So we can also make
stretchable solar cells.
And so it's your
choice of design
of what substrate you
would like to use.
And so you can think
about applications
which are not solar fields.
And I think you saw many of
those kinds of applications
tonight.
And so to complete the device--
I just showed you one
layer-- basically,
you have to do this
several more times.
And the second layer
is actually the layer
that absorbs the sun's light.
And this actually
is a blue car paint.
So it's very cheap.
It contains copper,
the cathode is silver.
And the way you
put them together
actually allows you to hook
up solar cells in series
to get the voltage
that you want.
We're doing 250 cells.
The other two things that are
nice about this particular way
of fabricating cells are
that all the elements
that are in this device are
things that are Earth abundant.
So you can find
carbon everywhere
and sulfur everywhere.
We don't have
things like indium,
which are many conventional
solar cells, which
are a rare Earth metals.
And also make the
cells more expensive.
And when you put this all
together and you test it,
you can actually
get out 50 volts
from this seven centimeter
square piece of paper.
And you can use this
to drive devices.
So I want to show you
a couple of movies.
This is a smaller piece
of that paper solar cell.
And it was encapsulated
in plastic.
And we'll light it
from the bottom.
This is AM 1.5 light.
That's typically what's
used to simulate the sun.
And you can see that you can
in fact drive this LED clock.
And this is being done in air.
So one of the knocks
against organic solar cells
is they tend to be nondurable.
So this is the cheapest
role to role reactor
we have in our lab-- or our
little Laserjet printer.
And we put it through--
the cell through there
to show that it survives
the flexing and thermal cycles.
We wanted to print something--
we're not very creative.
We just put MIT on there.
That's what happens.
But after it goes through
that process, it still works.
And I have demos
with me here that
have been around for
a year and a half now.
And the vapor process
just as much pure.
And so some of the degradation
mechanisms are gone.
Not only can we
flex solar cells,
we actually can fold them.
So here, you see this particular
cell's putting out 26 volts.
This again is in air.
And you'll see the hands of
Myles Clark Bar actually coming
in and folding up
the solar cell.
And the volt meter
shows the voltage drops.
And we expect that
because there's less
cross-section with the light.
But as you expand the
solar cell back out,
you can see that the
voltage again increases.
And I think this
form factor naturally
you'd think about
foldable blinds
that you could have
as indoor solar cells,
perhaps with
batteries on the head
or directly connected
to a lighting system.
And that way, you would get rid
of all the transmission losses
that you have in traditional--
a traditional lighting
system in a house.
And the final movie
here is the solar cell.
This one looks a
little bit different.
So in the first movie, you saw
that we used plastic lamination
like you would have
for driver's license.
In the second movie, we
had no lamination at all.
In this one, we
do another method
from our lab that puts
on a hydrophobic coating.
And here, you can actually
see that the solar cell can
go underwater and it still
retains its papery quality.
It has two axis bending.
So if you have plastic, it'll
just roll up into a cylinder.
But paper and textiles actually
have to access bending.
So this particular
piece of solar cell,
you're handling
fairly roughly in air
and putting it under water.
And it continues to put out
the same amount of voltage
that you have here.
And you can see that this
really is much more lightweight
and much more flexible than the
traditional solar cells that
exist.
And we're really excited about
improving the efficiency.
Currently, this cell would
be about 1% efficient.
We hope by the end of this
year, we'll have 5% efficiency.
And that will really start to
be interesting for designing
novel applications in solar.
And some of those
are pictured here.
What if you had wallpaper
that was actually solar cells?
You had a jacket you could wear
to charge your mobile device.
We've actually created a
solar cell on a postage stamp
just as a demonstration of size.
This one was 2% efficient.
Curtains, I think, Sheila's
had some designs and thoughts
about that.
If you just want to
put them on your roof,
it's much more
lightweight and you
don't have to do structural
changes to your building
to be able to support the heavy
weight of the solar cells.
Or you can take the power
with you with the tents.
So I hope that we're able
to do this in a large area
with the roll to
roll processing.
We've been working on this
for about five years now.
And I hope that will
really be at scale
that this can be commercial in
another three to five years.
So it does take
continued investment.
And I'd be happy if you
have any ideas about where
these solar cells on
paper could be used.
I'd love to hear them.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, well, that was
really exciting.
Thank you both for
your presentations.
Since both of you are
looking at a soft version--
you've called it soft.
In your case, clearly
it's foldable,
it's all these other things.
What have you found?
How have you seen this as
a paradigm shift in solar?
This idea of softness
and flexibility.
What are the--
beyond the attributes
that you started to
outline, how do you
see this as something
that is remarkably
different than the
rooftop solar array
that we've seen previously?
I mean, even for
the rooftop array,
just lowers the barrier
to implementation.
You think about
installing it yourself.
You could staple it to the roof.
You don't need a professional
installer to do that.
And I think the mobility of
something that's lightweight
is also clearly valuable.
For me, I think what's really
cool about the new materials is
the Earth abundant.
And the fact that
you could actually
recapture some of
those materials
at the end of their
life lifecycle.
You might be able to take that
t-shirt and be able to then
extract some of the
ITO or whatever it is--
the different solar
layers and recapture that.
So I think that's a
complete revolution
in terms of infrastructure.
We think of
infrastructure as hard.
We think about technologies
having a single form.
And really, since, I think,
the early period of the wars,
we've been thinking about that.
So the idea that it
can be adaptable,
that it could exist on different
substrates is super exciting.
Well, I think people have
been obsessed with efficiency
in solar panels for a
long time, which we've
been talking about tonight.
And so there's always
this drive to get
to a more efficient thin
film or in this case, paper.
So I think what I've
heard you talk about
in the past is this
idea of generous excess
where you have a material
that has less of an output
but has more applications.
So it's less tied to a specific
solar angle or something.
Yeah, I think Jeff was
also talking about that.
Yeah, exactly.
As material costs become
less and you have a low heat
way of printing
fairly large areas
or even smaller areas in a
very cost effective way, then
I think you really do change
the idea of efficiency.
And so if something
is easy to make
and has a low
environmental footprint,
it doesn't have to
last 20 to 25 years.
It could, but it
doesn't have to.
Because we can dispose of
it just in the same way
we drop a leaf on the ground and
a tree will grow another leaf.
So it's a pretty radical new
way of thinking of things.
Yeah.
I do think the solar industry
currently is very conservative.
And all of these criteria
for lasting really
go with being out
in a solar field.
So they want stability
that last 20 years.
But if you really want a solar
cell that perhaps integrates
directly with your cell
phone to charge it,
no one is keeping their
cell phone 20 years.
And so there's
absolutely no reason
that that should be
a barrier to entry
for these new technologies.
It's true.
We're being asked--
innovators and creators are
being asked to compare
new solar materials
or emerging solar
materials with mainstream
electrical technologies.
And so 25 years, all
this kind of stuff.
And if you think about
it, that wasn't the way
that even mainstream
electricity developed.
Edison went to the capital
and-- various different capitals
in Europe.
He went to Berlin.
And he asked people
whether they would
like to be the first
European capital
to have his AC
distribution system.
And they said, what do you mean?
We're going to put
poles in the ground
and then you're going to
have wires going in between?
And that's going
to be electricity?
And he said, yes.
And they said, forget it.
So his first application
was actually a DC generator
on board a ship.
A very small scale--
what we would call a
niche application today.
But that's really how mainstream
electricity and our grid
that we know today got started.
Through a series of
these very inventive
and kind of corner markets.
And I think it's
very interesting
that these mobile
applications, you're
seeing them insert
in rural areas
because then you
don't really have
to compete against grid power.
And I think that
that is essential.
And also transportation
that works in these areas
are very limited.
And so being lightweight is
really a critical factor.
Being foldable, you don't want
to take this huge glass panel
and try to get it up some
Rocky Mountain road somewhere.
Because breakability, even
though it's good for grant
getting and mayors, it can
cause trouble out in the field.
Glare.
Oh, glare.
Sorry.
Her device works too well.
Yeah.
I'll just ask one more
question, then I'll open it up.
So you kind of are getting at
it with the Edison comment.
But we've always
thought about technology
as something that's had to
be scaled to an incredibly
large degree for it
to be cost effective
and distributable
and all these things.
But it seems like in
both cases, what you're
doing is interesting
in that it actually
doesn't have to scale in the
conventional way we think of.
You're talking about
engaging local communities.
something that can be--
we can imagine a
future where this
could be something that
happens, if not in the home,
near a home.
Because it's a clean technology.
So it doesn't have to be out
in the outskirts of the city
sequestered where
it can be polluting.
And we live in the city
where it's not polluting.
Right.
So I was just wondering--
I mean, it seems like this is,
again, like a paradigm shift.
And so in your eyes, is it
necessary to bring these ideas
to a large scale?
Or what is exciting
about them that they're
nimble at these smaller scales?
I actually think one
of the exciting things
about our process is
that it's scalable
and that you could do
it in these large roll
to roll reactors.
And that just the reams of
rolls of paper could come out.
And then they're very easily
transportable and usable
by people without
professional installation.
Or you can just take it
wherever you want it.
So I like the scale and
the mobility together.
I think that's the
interesting intersection.
I agree.
All right.
Question.
Does it matter the
location if you're
printing some sort of
cells on your jacket?
[INAUDIBLE] Will it be better
for the people in Boston
to be wearing these
jackets [INAUDIBLE]??
Well of course,
different materials
have different what's
called solar apertures.
And I think Jeff talked
a little bit about this.
But with glass-based silicon
monocrystalline cells,
they have a relatively
narrow aperture,
which means that you need to
have light directly fall on
them more or less
within a range.
Organic solar, and to
some extent, these panels,
which are inorganic--
CIGS-- have a broader aperture.
So you can talk about light
that accrues over the whole day.
In general, on the
organic and something
that's flexible like
this allows you to not
have to walk at a 45
degree angle, for example--
which might be
painful and awkward--
in order to collect energy
with something on your back.
So you want to be able
to catch incident light.
That said you still need to
have your solar panel in light.
So you would need to
be committed to spend
a fairly long time outdoors.
Say five to six hours in
order to collect power
to charge a cell phone
or to run a light--
an LED lights say for
six hours or on low,
let's say, for a 24 hours.
So you need to be out there
with your jacket in the sun.
Does it matter if
I'm north or south.
Of course.
The principle of
the solar panels
that it needs to see sunlight
and it needs to convert
that sunlight into electricity.
The solar factor that immersed
in water, how does [INAUDIBLE]??
So it has on it
a very thin layer
of a fluoropolymer,
which is hydrophobic.
So the device itself actually
never sees the water.
It had almost the same principle
as that heavy plastic that's
on it, but just that
a much thinner level
so it still behaves like paper.
So [INAUDIBLE] I was working
on designing that [INAUDIBLE]
your team for a solar
light [INAUDIBLE]
because of their
glass-like behavior
and because of the
connection to them.
[INAUDIBLE] when I look
products that you're working on,
I wish [INAUDIBLE] that the
solar cell that you're holding
is as tough [INAUDIBLE] if
you're putting it on your roof
that you can drive a
nail straight through it.
Maybe you loose a cell
or two, but at the end
of the day, [INAUDIBLE]
That is true with this.
For example, you can
put punch holes in this
and it will still operate.
You can also partially shade
and it can still operate.
So it has a lot of
benefits that way.
And we just try to
use it structurally,
so it's sort of part
of the structure
that the textile
acts in tension.
And then we compress
this and so we sort of
try to build the
structure with it.
Yeah.
I mean, I think you
saw in the videos
I had different sized cells.
They were all made the same way.
We actually use
scissors to cut them
into different
shapes for testing.
I did have one
incident where I was
talking to a large
group at MIT and I
passed around one of these.
And someone actually tore
off the corner of the cell
to keep for themselves.
But the rest still worked
because they're really--
the way they're
connected in series.
But if you had a lot of this,
there's really a lot of things
that you can do in terms of
the foldability of the cells.
And if they're really cheap
enough and you do destroy them,
it's easy to replace.
I have a question
for you, Karen.
On those the 50 volts
or those other metrics,
are those like open
circuit voltage?
Or if you apply
to load or if you
looked at the sweet spot of
powerpoint tracking, what
would be the kind of
typical yield in terms
of current in voltage?
Because that's important
for applications.
Right.
So the voltage there was the
VOC for everything in series.
And I can't remember the current
number off the top of my head.
We used it to drive
an LED display, which
needs a relatively low current.
We actually don't have enough
current to drive and LED
on right now.
So we really need to be
more efficient to do that.
But at 5%, you should--
Absolutely, yeah.
Cool.
I thought your projects that you
described just were fantastic,
as well as the one
we heard earlier.
Jeff had talked about 3D.
And he showed some
pretty [INAUDIBLE]
designs, but mentioned that it
was difficult right now to get
into the shapes that
[INAUDIBLE] your paper cells
[INAUDIBLE] the bill.
Is there any collaboration or
any potential for maybe making
this [INAUDIBLE] he
was talking to put--
Yeah.
I think so.
I think that would be a
tremendous collaboration.
And also because of
the ability to fold,
you don't need a
static 3D shape.
So you could
actually transform it
to take best
advantage of the sun
as it tracks across the sky.
I also think it's just
sometimes just a neat challenge.
Since I'm kind of
living in the world of,
let's do something now.
I'm an architect, so
we do do research.
But we generally, get really
excited about making things
and building things and
seeing things out in the world
working.
And so one thing that
you can also think about
as a designer is,
just how can you
work with the design
of the cell as it is?
Do you really need to change it?
Or can you find a way to
kind of work with that?
So one of the things about
the silicon and the hard cells
is that they tend to be square.
That's because they're made
out of a log of silicon
and then that's cut.
And then actually, there's
quite a bit of waste
to go from circle to a square.
Then there are defects.
So you have to check for those.
And so those square
glass cells are sometimes
difficult to work with in
terms of design intent.
Yeah.
I think what's really
interesting about what
Sheila's doing--
I think there's
Clayton Christensen
has the innovator's dilemma.
It says what can you do with
parts that already exist?
And I think we don't know
really how people will interact
with the solar or how
much they'll pay for it
or what uses
they'll find for it.
And I think when they
do, the next generations
of technologies to come in are
even cheaper or more flexible
can just insert into
those modes of operation.
How far away from [INAUDIBLE]
I think just [INAUDIBLE]
how far from having regular car
driving on solar [INAUDIBLE]??
Well, today, there
are cars that have
flexible solar panels, actually
the same material but larger.
You see that integrated
into a curved roof.
And typically they're
going to power some subset
of applications in the car.
For example, air conditioning.
You can have a direct
drive solar panel, which
means you don't need a battery.
But when the sun
hits that car, it'll
circulate a fan which will help
make the air conditioning more
effective in the car.
Or there can be a certain
DC load in the car--
car is a DC platform--
that will be taken up--
let's say the dashboard--
by that particular power source.
The other thing I would
say is that, again,
we in the electricity grid,
look for total everything.
Black or white,
like the whole car.
The whole city.
The whole world.
And what we're
going to need to see
is that there are
going to be steps.
There are going to be
multiple power sources.
There's going to
be a transition--
an energy transition,
it's called--
as we start developing
some things off grid,
but not everything off grid.
And so we'll have to
get used to these ideas
of multiple sources,
partial powering,
objects that we plug-in, objects
that we take with us, objects
that we charge in our lives.
So there's going to be
much more of a plurality I
think of energy sources.
We have time for
one more question?
Along these lines [INAUDIBLE]
I've thought a lot.
And I've worked with Jeff on
a similar project that right
now is not in the public realm.
But a very interesting
project about taking sunlight
and bringing it into buildings.
But I think 3D is
really interesting.
And I think that the
algorithm that he has that
takes inputs and then generates
a series of responses to that,
throwing out the ones that--
the ancestors that don't work
and continuing on
is very interesting.
So I think we could
be much more creative.
We're stuck in what
Jimmy Carter did in 1978.
He had all the good
intentions in the world.
But he put a solar panel
in the White House.
Put it like flat on.
He said that's it.
And we've just accepted that.
That that should be what solar
panels do, how they operate.
That they're glass.
That they're hard.
That they have to have direct
sunlight, et cetera, et cetera.
And this materials
revolution that we've
touched on in this
panel is, I think,
going to change a lot of that.
And I think the
investment in solar right
now would be very difficult
to get a company funded
in the solar area.
Green energy has been viewed as
being a very poor investment.
There were bankruptcies
like Solyndra.
There's been huge consolidations
in the solar producers really
driving each other the prices
below what can be sustained.
And so you have huge
companies going bankrupt.
And I think it really
hurts the technology.
And someone really
needs to sustain it.
I first did solar energy
when I was a graduate student
25 years ago.
And after my thesis, I
didn't do it for 20 years.
And that's true of
a lot of scientists.
And all the momentum from 25
years ago was generally lost.
Most of those people
did not pick up again.
And so it would be
unfortunate if we lost
this round of momentum as well.
Please join me in making
our [INAUDIBLE] panelists
and [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you all for joining
us for tonight's program.
I hope you found it as sort
of inspiring and fascinating
as I did.
We heard from a number of
people about their very varied
projects.
Their very different approaches
to using solar technology
to developing technologies
to harness solar power.
And I think we might all
sort of think on our own
what new projects we might
want to pursue or support,
how solar maybe isn't what
we always thought it was.
It actually takes
many shapes and forms
and has some pretty wonderful
applications for people,
not just in our own community,
but around the world.
Thank you very much to our
panelists and moderators.
Thank you very much.
And thank you all for
joining us this evening.
Have a good night.
[APPLAUSE]